there's almost a countless number of
easter eggs scattered across the movies
of the mcu
some are subtle while others are far
more obvious and although it's almost
impossible to list them all these are a
few that you might have just missed
for years on end the worlds of the
avengers and the x-men have been kept
separate on the big screen thanks to a
conflict in usage rights between various
studios
while the avengers assembled at marvel
studios the mutants had their own
adventures over at fox but that doesn't
mean there haven't been any knowing
winks exchanged between the two
during one scene in iron man tony stark
conducts a test flight of his new armor
for the first time and decides to see
just how high he can fly
he asks his ai assistant jarvis what the
altitude record is for a very specific
plane
all right let's see what this thing can
do what's sr-71's record the altitude
record for fixed-wing flight is 85 000
feet
that's a real plane of course but it
also has a place in the marvel universe
the sr-71 blackbird was used as the
model for the jet flown to missions by
the x-men
and has often been referred to as the
blackbird whenever it's not being called
the x-jet
now iron man can't exactly specify that
stark was referring to charles xavier's
private super plane but it was a nice
nod in the direction of x-men fans
nonetheless
captain america the first avenger takes
marvel fans back to world war ii
not only the era in which steve rogers
became captain america
but also the time during which the
character was created in real life
but he wasn't the only superhero to come
out of this period during the stark
expo scene eagle-eyed viewers will be
able to spot another classic marvel
character who was created back when the
company was still known as timely comics
as steve bucky and their dates walk
through the expo
they pass a glass display case with a
costume in it labeled dr phineus horton
presents the synthetic man
horton is the scientist who created the
original human torch all the way back in
marvel comics number one
this character was initially kept in a
glass cylinder much like the one in
captain america
remains an important piece of the
foundations of the marvel universe
this particular shot establishes that
some version of him existed in the mcu
at some point so
maybe one day we'll flash back again and
get the full story of synthetic man and
his adventures
the marvel cinematic universe may be a
world unto itself but it exists in the
greater realm of marvel entertainment
which itself contains a vast multiverse
of various worlds featuring many
alternate versions of its characters
the mcu even has its own designated
reality number
19999 this places it within the greater
marvel universe meaning that
whether we'll ever see it or not there's
a cosmic link between the cinematic
versions of these characters and their
prime continuity comic book counterparts
that link was further emphasized in thor
the dark world
when eric selvig laid out his
understanding of reality on a giant
chalkboard during his time in a mental
institution
among his scribblings are the words 616
universe
the official designation of the main
marvel comics universe
any questions
yeah can i have my shoe back although
stan lee's cameos and marvel movies have
become
practically legendary lee isn't the only
marvel luminary to pop up in the mcu at
one point or another
one of the most notable instances of his
fame came during captain america the
winter soldier
as alexander pierce is questioning the
winter soldier a team of handlers are
standing around the room
one of them seen on the left is ed
brubacher an eisner award-winning comic
book writer responsible for resurrecting
bucky barnes as the winter soldier in
captain america number
one back in 2005. before brubaker joined
captain america bucky had been dead for
decades and was long considered one of
the rare comics characters who would
never return from the grave
without brubacher the mcu would be a
very different place indeed so
it's nice to see him get a little moment
of recognition here
no easter egg within the entirety of the
mcu is quite as bountiful as the
collector's hideaway on nowhere in
guardians of the galaxy
his massive treasure trove of artifacts
and living specimens seems to go on
forever
and if you're willing to be a little
liberal with the pause button you're
likely to notice quite a few
interesting things very well then
let us see what you brought among his
items are a chitari warrior from the
avengers a dark elf from
thor the dark world cosmo the space dog
and of course
powered the duck however there's one
more find tucked away in that room that
could have
wide reaching implications for the
future of the mcu
it's possible to spot a certain
cocoon-like object that writer-director
james gunn later hinted was the
gestation place of adam warlock a
character further teased in a
post-credits scene from volume 2.
as it turns out the two objects might
not be the exact same cocoon but the
visual cues are difficult to ignore
adam warlock has massive cosmic
implications for marvel's future so if
he does show up at some point
we can probably tie it all back to this
some easter eggs are so obscure that
you'll only recognize
them if you carefully read one very
specific comic book
that's the case here with this gem from
captain america civil war
at peggy carter's funeral her niece
sharon delivers the eulogy
and passes on some words of wisdom her
aunt once shared with her
even if the whole world is telling you
to move
it is your duty to plant yourself like a
tree
look them in the eye and say no it's a
powerful moment for certain comic book
readers however it was made all the more
powerful by the fact that it's a speech
lifted largely from amazing spider-man
number 537
a comic tying in to the original civil
war event in which a
very similar speech is given by none
other than captain america himself
screenwriters christopher marcus and
steven mcfeely definitely did their
homework with this one
some easter eggs may begin as an amusing
idea but sadly just don't come together
and fail to ever reach a satisfying
payoff
in the mcu where some parts of the
universe are attempting to work with the
same concepts as others
this can happen a lot for example it was
the case with one particular hidden gem
in doctor strange which has been
semi-retconned by the events of hulu's
runaways tv series
at various points in the film we see
glimpses of the hong kong sanctum where
sorcerers work to guard that particular
corner of the world from a host of
magical threats
among them is a staff-wielding character
named tina minoru
played in doctor strange by linda louise
duan we only know her name because she's
listed in the credits but minoru happens
to be the
mother of nico minoru one of the main
stars of runaways
who eventually wields her mother's staff
herself of course tina minoru was recast
for runaways but
it's still a nice touch some marvel
characters might not be ready for prime
time yet but are still loved by enough
fans and filmmakers to make at least a
brief appearance in the mcu
one instance of this happening occurs
during thor ragnarok when we see the
grand masters palace on sakhar for the
first time
this towering structure is adorned with
various shimmering statues depicting the
heads of champions who have fought in
the arena
and while the hulk head under
construction might end up dominating the
whole thing the heads that have already
been built are particularly fascinating
for comic book fans
they include bye beast man thing ares
and even beta ray bill a long time ally
of thor who fans have been hoping to see
on the big screen for years
we may not see any of these characters
actually living and breathing in the mcu
anytime
soon but these statues were enough to
let us know they exist
and that's a good start avengers
infinity war is very loosely based on
the 1991 marvel comics event series the
infinity gauntlet
while the plot of the movie differs
significantly from its origin story the
film
bears many nods and links to the text
for example bruce banner crashes through
the roof of dr strange's sanctum echoing
the moment when the silver surfer did
the same thing in the comics
i understood that reference of all the
moments that made gauntlet fans happy
however
one that really stands out comes in the
film's very last shot when
thanos sits down at his humble farm to
watch the sun rise on a grateful
universe
as he walks through the hut you'll see
something standing amid the crops
growing
outside a scarecrow made from his old
battle armor
at the end of infinity gauntlet thanos
gives up his quest for ultimate power
after the battle
takes up farming and makes a scarecrow
with his armor
these may be two very different ways of
arriving at the same image but it's a
great reference nonetheless